so how loud can i go i need you to back
it up a little bit i'll be right over
there yeah someone tells me because
one time i dj in brazil and somebody
touched it for one second and then
everyone was talking about me
just because they didn't have the main
volume up so
don't want that to happen again at my
first concert i was opening up a music
festival for jennifer lopez and after
that i just fell in love with it it's
one of my favorite things that i do in
life so i take it very seriously both
sides are
[Music]
it won't be that weird
[Music]
all right let's go upstairs and get
changed
i hope people don't think that was
actually my set
can i have a phone so i can pretend to
be on it in case i get buried
oh my god i'm so stressed it's almost
nine go back change chill for a second
and we're done hello guys
i love your outfit
yo i'm going to change
[Music]
but we're so late
the dj said outfit that's so cute cute
i love it were you inspired by
a different look for britney
so remember in toxic when she's on the
plane and she was like the hot flight
attendant so it's like that type of vibe
i love that look parasized it's like the
sexy body chain
let's do this you ready
i'm so nervous no you're not nervous
i'm so stressed out like the brain
the soundtrack
like if that happens again i'm going to
have to talk i always get shy and
nervous as soon as i'm about to go on
stage but as soon as i start playing the
music
just all of the nervousness goes away i
just feel just so happy and excited
and just having the best time
you've done this once
but i'm happy you're here
[Music]
where's my yes
i hadn't seen her dj for
a long time she never let me watch
during coven when she was doing virtual
dj she goes oh my god i'm so nervous and
embarrassed when you're here i was like
paris there's i'm the only one watching
you're used to doing tomorrowland when
there's 500 000 people she said
just having you watching the living room
is way worse
watching paris dj is awesome she has
this sparkle and she has these dance
moves and it's just so infectious
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up las vegas
vegas is back and i am so excited to be
here at resort's world and have a good
time with you guys
[Music]
[Music]
i
here was this child that
i thought would go
to school to be a veterinarian
and
you know wore jeans and t-shirts and
sneakers and all of a sudden
she changed
as a teenager all my parents would do is
try to get me out of the clubs but then
years later i proved them wrong i ended
up making a huge lucrative business and
basically invented getting paid to party
[Applause]
music has always been something that's
been extremely healing for me
and then when i'm djing it's just like
an escape from the world and i just
am on stage and literally feel like i'm
on top of the world like a rock star and
it's magical
[Music]
you